what would be your kind of top tips for
someone looking to become more camera
confident it's the scariest thing but
you have to just try it almost ready to
receive criticism and then unmask that
criticism into some useful feedback when
I first put my face on I knew that there
was going to be some comments there that
I wasn't excited to read yeah but I was
like well they'll be usefulness so there
are people like you idiot sit further
away from the camera and if you take
away you idiot that's actually a really
useful piece of feedback and then I did
that and then it's like get your
microphone out the frame and I'm like
okay and then I researched where do you
put microphones oh underneath okay great
I'll do that and slowly but surely you
start to move towards a quality that
you're actually proud of but you've got
to accept the fact that to start with it
won't be because you're watching people
who've been doing it for 10 years for
example
[Music]